hey there guys so on this channel i dive
into all sorts of different aspects
of fitness and performance and talk
about the benefits of combining them
instead of focusing on just one modality
one of the questions i get most often
though is how can you incorporate all
this into a workout
and still have time for anything else
and the answer is that you're not just
combining lots of different stuff all on
top of each other but rather you're
kind of using exercises that bring
multiple benefits
what i like to call bang for your buck
exercises
and so in this video i'm going to break
down a few different exercises give you
some practical things you can do
to build strength and performance and
endurance
all at once in a very functional manner
of course every exercise has its place
and i'm not saying some exercises are
more functional than others but if you
want
an exercise that gives you lots of
different benefits all at once
and an exercise that's going to transfer
to things like athletic performance
martial arts and everyday health and
mobility
then this is the list should do you
nicely i've got other videos like this
on the channel as well where i break
down different exercises so after you've
watched this one
maybe go and check those out as well and
of course if you want an entire program
built around these kinds of movements
and this kind of philosophy
then be sure to check out the link in
the description that will take you to
super functional training my ebook and
training program and there's a discount
on right now
whilst we're all in lockdown anyways
without further ado
here's my list
for this you're going to take a cable or
a band and then press it forwards on one
side against resistance
you're challenging the pushing muscles
the pecs the triceps and the shoulders
but also the ability to brace the core
the press is an anti-rotational movement
the aim is to not let your body twist
from side to side
here you're standing with the legs
slightly apart looking square ahead
the aim then is to push out whilst
keeping your torso steady
pushing from a mechanically
disadvantaged position just as you might
have to in real life
so the atlas swing is another exercise
with an awesome name
this is a swing that travels
horizontally across the body with a
twisting motion
this builds impressive ballistic power
in the core along the transverse plane
so you're going to take up a regular
stance with the legs slightly bent and
shoulder width apart
grip the kettlebell handle in both hands
and then swing to one side
turn as you do to face that direction
the kettlebell should hang for a moment
at the top of the movement
now let it come back down in front of
you like a pendulum twist at the waist
and shift your weight onto the other
foot as it reaches the apex on the other
side
you want to really drive through the
core here as you twist and swing the
weight
and this is going to develop that
twisting power that's so useful
in so many different aspects of life and
sports
so every kind of medicine ball slam is a
fantastic
ballistic exercise that requires you to
exert sudden explosive force
against the resistance provided by the
medicine ball and this lets you
perform all sorts of movements that
mimic things you might actually do
whether in daily life or on the field
in the case of a rotational slam you're
taking the ball and then you're throwing
it against a wall or just into the
distance by twisting
and talking the torso you can do this
throwing overhand like a shot perch or
you can sling it
from the waist height as a concentric
only exercise it's a great finisher
and of course it also translates very
nicely as a form of cardio
and resistance cardio at that once again
this makes it highly
bang for your buck exercise
this will build the ability to
explosively return energy from a single
leg or stabilizing the hips
to perform this movement you're going to
keep one leg on the ground and the other
raised in a bent position
squat by bending the supporting leg
keeping the foot flat
and you're going to bring the other leg
backwards so the shin is parallel with
the ground
you're going to bring your free leg up
and drive the knee into the air
as you jump off of that one supporting
leg what's important here is not
squatting
low but jumping high and forcefully it's
important to note that the aim is not to
reach
failure with single leg squat jumps in
fact you should be stopping before
you even reach technical failure because
the risk of injury this one as you get
fatigued
becomes extraordinarily high this is
also only an advanced move for people
who
really know what they're doing and have
developed a lot of single leg strength
and stability
through other exercises
the problem is that using sprints in a
workout regularly can increase your
chance of
injury it's very high impact and if
you're going at top speed it's very easy
to
trip over your own feet going uphill
reduces these risks because it allows
you to
put in 100 effort but not go quite such
a high speed
at the same time that added resistance
allows you to develop even more power
this also helps because you're
increasing the rate of your
stride you're also bringing your knees
up higher and at the same time this
forces you to land on the balls of your
feet
which can reduce injury so running
uphill basically is a way to
add resistance to sprints which is a
fantastic way to make you faster
so i've talked about calf jumps in the
past as a fantastic tool for building
explosive strength in the calves which
can contribute to a
better vertical jump and at the same
time this is excellent for developing
ankle stiffness which is a very
underappreciated
aspect of athletic performance a lot of
athletic performance is about
returning energy to the ground as jc
santana
from institute of human performance told
me rather than generating power yourself
it's not about fast twitch it's not
about fast twitch
because what transfers is almost an
isometric contraction
so you go okay the first bridge is the
is the angle
and that's the one that everybody misses
because when you want to run fast the
first thing they do is leg pressing
squat
deadlifts if you're a little bit more uh
advanced you go into your single leg
pumps and your single leg uh squat uh
and that kind of stuff
if you're more progressive uh you go
into understanding that the hamstrings
pulling so you start doing your triple
threat with
with the stability ball and all of that
but everybody misses
the simplest thing to develop and the
usually the biggest thing missing
especially at the low levels which is
ankle stiffness
yeah therefore well how do you develop
that do
easy easy single leg skip roping you
don't even need a skip rope
and that's where the ankle stiffness
comes in using calf jumps is a great way
to build this
but what's more useful is to try
skipping
on just one foot but at the same time
this is a bang for your buck exercise
because it also allows you to train
things like coordination and of course
cardio don't have a rope that's fine you
can actually perform
one-legged skipping without even using a
rope
just pretend you've got one
you feel a little bit weird
but i guess
so here you're going to pick up either a
rock a boulder or a log
now you're going to get it into a racked
position so that your arms are bent now
you're going to push the weight upwards
for reps
the benefit of using something like this
rather than a barbell is that every rock
and every boulder are different
this means that you'll need to adapt
your grip and core stability every
single time
you'll be easing the weight slightly
more onto one side or the other side
you'll have to contort your body this
builds tough hands and hardy mentality
you can use other things like backpacks
stuffed with weight or sandbags
or if you live near the woods then ideal
just go for it
this is what nikolai bernstein refers to
as repetition without repetition
and this can help us to build more
robust mental models
that store our motor movements basically
your mental model becomes
more generalized so as to be applicable
to more situations
and thus more useful in the real world
so thanks for watching this one guys i
hope you found it useful and interesting
if you did then
please share it around leave a like
subscribe all that stuff helps me
immensely i've got much more like this
on the way so stay tuned
thanks so much for your support and i'll
see you next time
bye for now